on portrait de l'artiste
[Musique]
notre philosophie que jean hubert est
également un collectionneur d'art
primitif
après s'être confronté à la culture des
dogons du mali où des hopis d'arizona
ici il explore d'autres formes comme le
triangle un symbole divin alors cet
achat pessah les limaces de dieu ces
lieux l absolu ya les limaces et limaces
qui sont par rapport au triangle que
c'est une des deux définitions ordre de
l'absolu c'était un peu une définition
du berry crise mais parce que je trouve
partout ici
d'abord des formes là c'est l'architecte
qui s'exprime et puis des couleurs c'est
le poète qui prend la main ensuite il
blanchir à son tableau
sous ces blancs la lumière sous et dans
chaque forme géométrique un léger
déséquilibre fait vibrer la toile
je compose une chose je le mets en
équilibre et après je place quelque
chose tu as le petit truc tellement
déséquilibre qui va le rendre
intéressant le tableau aujourd'hui jean
hubert se pose pour que l'esprit de la
nature berrichonne raisonne en lui c'est
chanté des chants tellurique je sais pas
ce que c'est mais enfin bref or quand on
arrive dans un lieu et quand se sent
bien heureux et cetera en harmonie avec
cette nature voilà c'est comme ça il n'y
a pas trop d'explications